[Music]
after the consumathon of black friday
and cyber monday today is giving tuesday
it's a global movement that encourages
people to give back to their community
more than 34 million people participated
in giving tuesday last year they do
things like volunteering donating goods
or clothes supporting local
organizations national organizations you
name it well this year supply chain
problems and rising inflation have led
to higher prices for everyday items like
groceries gas housing it's become more
difficult for families who live on a
fixed income well our vlad duterte is
outside our studios here in times square
with how one group is drawing extra
attention to this giving tuesday
movement vlad with a costume change good
morning again
i got one of those velcro suits tony
like they had in the naked gun uh look
it's beginning to feel a lot like
christmas and the salvation army has
just unveiled the world's largest red
kettle right here in times square it is
32 feet tall 16 feet wide and lights up
every time someone makes a donation so
here's what's going on they have doubled
the number of meals served to people in
need during the pandemic which is so
important donations go to food pantries
they go to senior centers they go to
toys for kids and also music programs
this is just one example of how
nonprofits are helping people in need on
this giving tuesday listen to this
number in 2020 over 2 billion were
donated in 24 hours in the united states
alone so here are a few steps that you
can take to help your community today
give your time or your talent like
volunteering with a non-profit or
community center donate goods like
clothes or non-perishables and maybe
instead of spending that five bucks on a
latte
maybe instead make a donation to a cause
you really care about and the easiest
thing you can do right now most
important thing anybody can do right now
in these difficult times is to give some
kindness in other words don't be a
grinch this holiday
none of you guys are i don't know any
grinches in my life i don't know about
you back to you
all right i know okay i know that's
right what does that say about us tony
we know a couple of grinch is